Jason Harris I'm a senior developer for
Wolfram research going to be talking
about authoring content for the Wolfram
player for the iPad I'm gonna be going
into a lot of detail about authoring
more advanced packages for the actual
player and a lot of details to do with
loading up packages and other advanced
topics thank you okay well I'll go ahead
and get started
Jason Harris developer and Wolfram
research with Rob and the others I work
on the the player and before that the
main front end so you've seen it it's
here the player it's fantastic it's it's
occupied the last I don't know seven
years five years of our lives and we're
all very proud of it and it's been a
real pleasure to actually work on to
actually get it to go it's been kind of
daunting but it's here it's great it's
fantastic so you've seen Rob's talk and
he's demonstrated a lot of the
functionality of a normal sort of player
application you've got a notebook you've
got some controls maybe some manipulates
some titles some cells but the question
I'd like to sort of address now and it's
for us now that we've actually got it
how far can we push it we want to do
complex sort of calculations we want to
load a package how do we get it going
how do we build up something where we
have a collection of notebooks that are
linked how far can we push it and that's
really the sort of topic of this talk
okay and so during this talk I'm going
to use one of the examples I'm going to
build up to this example and peer to
peer lending so the talk is somewhat
schizophrenic it's somewhat split of
being interested in peer-to-peer lending
myself of pumps and money I've actually
spent some of my hard-earned cash on
peer-to-peer lending and so I've written
some simulations of this and I've got a
package and we want to build up some of
the tools we need to to be able to
actually visualize some stuff to do with
peer-to-peer lending on on the iPad so
it manipulates I'll mention you've seen
them with Rob's talk here we we go and
here's one of the the talks that we've
got that's sorry one of the notebooks we
used in our development and of course a
normal notebook is this is just a
be it's you can scroll it it's got nice
typesetting so on this is a kind of
normal application and it's got a you
know a manipulate here and we've got
this control raft down the bottom and
and we can move it onto the the right
side or top left and bottom then you
know the controls work and we can
visualize here's nice you know line
integral and so on so that's the kind of
standard notebook and so I won't talk
about that too much I'll then move on to
the the is player and I'll mention if
you've been in Rob's talk here there's
some specific things we've done for the
player like the touch screen control
placement so we can put the raft instead
of on the bottom on the right or left
the touch position locator magnifiers
Rob didn't talk about that but that's
also specific on the on the player and
in fact there's a whole host of various
options we've done in customization
we've done for the iPad version and so I
will say since it's taken us five years
you might think well Jason and Rob were
just kind of stupid and slack but indeed
it's actually not the case in fact
there's a whole new core that's
underneath us and so this core it's it's
multi-threaded from the ground up and
it's very that's architectures you know
it's quite a nice modern architecture
and this allows us a lot of improvements
and of course we've got the fantastic
front end that if you went to John's
talk is like maybe 21 years ahead of
everybody else
and so of course with the modern systems
you get desktops with maybe 16 cores and
so we need multi-threading at some stage
and so we'll be bringing back some of
the advances we've got in the actual
player to the main front end and as we
move forward and unifying them as we go
but like Rob I'm going to point out some
of the the limitations and specifically
the limitations that I came across in
doing this talk one of them is the
parallel tools so since I'm running
simulations when I when I do this on my
laptop but took me maybe 10 minutes to
run the simulation and I did it with
parallel tools so it was even faster
than that
might have taken half an hour you know
in 40 minutes or an hour to do my
simulations but I can't do them on the
iPad because of course and on my on my
version here
but everything is all in the same
processor space so the front end in the
kernel live in the same processing space
and so I can't use parallel tools for
saving when we want to develop an actual
application we can't save anything on an
iPad so we need some sort of persistence
so we handle this in a way which I'll
talk about in a bit
notebook programming as well is somewhat
limited right now on the iPad this will
be something we'll be improving in the
near future working on it and so we'll
have the full capabilities a notebook
programming hopefully not not too not
too long from now and then you you come
across other various issues that are
more advanced so for instance I came
across that you know buttons with method
queued don't actually work right now all
of our controls we use the normal
standard pre-emptive link to send our
various control interaction with the
kernel okay so given those limitations
let's actually take a look and let's
actually mention that right now on the
iPad here we have apples really now
actually even talking about the local
file system so my iPad really has a
local file system and indeed we'll be
changing our file browser possibly at
some stage in the future to enable to
work with that file browser but one of
the one of the ways we can actually get
content on to the iPad I won't hook up
my laptop and show you because I'd have
to fiddle round but what you do this
thing the Apple call side loading and so
you load this up and you see it's
Jason's iPad pro you click on Wolfram
Player and over here we see the various
documents you just drag and drop some
various documents there and indeed we
can actually see here's this simulate p2
p.m. that's the package we're going to
be playing with here's my title they're
my talk and there's some other sorts of
stuff on the iPad so it's pretty easy to
actually get your content on so we can
get collections of notebooks that we
need to do complicated applications so
now and in fact I'm gonna I'm gonna pre
announce that there's one bug so this
isn't actually the shipping version this
is a bit more advanced and there's one
bug that I couldn't get fixed in time to
do with cell grouping so when I print
things locally it's going to open all
the so
groups and so but we'll just live with
that and then I'll be able to
demonstrate all the various bits and so
for an application we need some local
persistence so here's just a slider
dynamic nn and right here we're using
this local symbol of of X and we can
actually store that and so since we
don't have shift enter evaluation we
have to basically do all of our
evaluations by buttons so I'm doing this
for the illustration but then when we
come to have an actual application we'll
do it differently but so we can actually
see here we're going to store that in so
we're gonna store 6 factorial locally
and now I'm gonna do the quit the kernel
which is basically just quit the
application here load it up again our
version I'm going to do this several
times to show you I've got nothing up my
sleeve here and we're gonna load up this
local persistence and we'll actually see
when we print that local value 720 and
there there's the bug so it opened all
of our various sections there sorry
about that and there we see 720 so it's
stored the value locally even though
we've quit our sessions and even though
our slider of course is still on one
we've still got this value stored
locally so we need to do this when we're
building up applications and in fact if
you want to see more on this persistence
there's Romans talk which is actually
concurrent with this but you'll be able
to get the slides for that which we'll
talk about this this local symbol here
at the storage ok so let's talk about
actually loading a package you saw it's
now on our actual device and we can
actually say what is the notebook
directory where does this notebook
actually live and it's a somewhat
complicated private farm a little illa
but it's here and so as you've noticed
from my side loading my notebook this
iOS applications is right next to the
simulate p2p so what I can do is I can
just filename join our notebook
directory to this this simulator and
then we just use a normal needs of the
context and this will actually load the
package and so we've got no feedback we
want to fix that we want to have some
feedback but to actually see that the
package is loaded here's just a simple
simulation and I'll talk about the peer
to peer that in a second this but this
is just simulating a basket of five
thousand dollars invested across this
grade of loans and a peer-to-peer way
what's the annualized percentage return
and we're getting eleven point four nine
nine percent return from that and we
could simulate it again
maybe we dropped a little bit that time
and so we can do some simulations the
important thing is that we've loaded a
package with loaded a package here and
so we can build our complicated
applications loading external things so
let's actually now talk about the cloud
I've got my password hidden the version
I've loaded up onto passable of course
doesn't have my password in it but it's
sort of embedded and hidden there and we
can turn around and we can actually
connect to the cloud and now we can do
some various cloud put and cloud get to
to demonstrate our interaction with the
cloud if we need to and so an
application might need to call some
central server store some results load
some results and so here we have a
simple sort of button just to test it
and what we're going to do with this is
we're gonna do a cloud put of X to this
cloud object whole mr. cloud so we're
gonna cloud put some stuff to mr. cloud
by storing this three into mr. cloud and
there we go we've stored it and now we
could change this button again something
else and now we could just load it from
the cloud which is basically a cloud get
on the same object and indeed we get our
old value of three and so we could
change this we could store the seven in
change this or reset it or whatever and
again we've stored it so now and we can
do the same thing with cloud expressions
data bins they have been added and so on
so basically we can add and load or
store stuff into the cloud and of course
this goes back to John's question or
John's statement just there of can we
actually store our complete package on
the actual cloud and indeed we can so we
don't need to do the side loading we can
just get a notebook and we just you know
load it right from there something a
package that's completely updated all
the time and so to get the package onto
the cloud it's basically copy file
there's the path there's the the package
there and we're copying it to some cloud
object we're setting the permissions of
that to be public and now we just go
ahead and we're going to be just doing
this load package is quiet cloud get of
that of that of that object there is
this expand cloud object that's just to
make sure that these cloud objects have
a full path in them when I'm logged in
and connected it's just the sort of
local relative path but this expand
cloud object is it's it's in the netcode
it's not too too too hard so just to
show you again I'm going to quit the
kernel just
I've got that's not using the other
previous version I had there and so we
go to our cloud loading hit here load
the package and go get hit by our bug
again of opening all the sections there
we go
ouch sorry we will fix that and now we
can actually see we've loaded this
package directly from the cloud okay so
one of the things that we've got with
this we've got some we've got a problem
that that we don't want some people to
just have to load up the package and
click the initialization button that's
kind of ugly so what we want is we want
this to happen automatically and so
we've got this loading stuff here but
since it automatically loaded let me
show you that again it was a bit too
fast I'm gonna again quit the kernel
nothing up my sleeve starting from
scratch we have our order loading of
packages right there you see it loading
loading loading loading loading loading
loading loading loaded ok so what
happens is what we did is this dynamic
when it's actually loading up will
automatically turn around and kick off
the computation and so there's some
dynamic junk here to just you know make
sure the backgrounds you know green and
it looks nice and it has the right
that's but the real magic here is just
basically this dynamic if it doesn't
have a value load status doesn't have a
value it sets it to loading and it does
this session submit of pause of blah
so this pauses are stand-in here for
loading a package that could be you know
in needs it could be a cloud yet or so
on but it's using this session submit
and if you went and you listened to
Roger talk about this this session
submit gives us a way to an end to do
concurrent programming and so we can
sort of say in the idle time or the
kernels idling it can go ahead and
actually do something like load up the
package in the background
and that's quite nice and it sits around
so this would be one of the things we
need to actually have external loading
of an actual package ok
so now let me just sort of switch gears
a little bit and actually talk about
peer to peer lending and so that we can
actually build up this application to do
with this so
first of all we have to talk about
what's traditional banking well we
normally have a lender a bank and some
borrowers and what happens is the lender
turns around and gives the banks of
money as a term deposit the bank will
turn around and give that out to they'll
collect up a lot of that and then give
it to some people as a mortgage and the
borrower's well then over time have to
turn around and say make monthly house
payments their wage slaves to to pay off
their mortgage and in the end the bank
will take a fraction of that and give it
back and interest payments to the lender
and so that's all well and good
everybody understands that
except of course let's say when the
borrowers have some problems the economy
goes a little bit south some of those
people lose their jobs they can't make
payments to the bank the bank doesn't
have enough money to give to the lenders
the lenders all turn around say to the
bank give us all our money there's a run
on the bank the bank blows up and then
we get the global financial crisis and
it's all bad people don't like that so
there's thin tax have come up with some
of the the financial right the financial
wizards out there have come up with this
peer-to-peer lending and so instead of
this normal model of a lender a bank and
some borrowers what they do is they
basically get rid of the bank and that
they move to where we have a whole pool
of lenders a whole pool of borrowers and
this peer-to-peer organizer basically
they're a matchmaker and so what happens
if borrower number one here wants a loan
for $20,000 the various lenders here
along here they all give a small amount
lender one might give $25.00 lender two
might get 50 lender 3 might give 25
dollars again and so they all give
various amounts to this borrower one and
the borrower one actually turns around
then and gives some interest in
principal back to all the various
lenders and so these lenders since
they're only giving small amounts of
money $25.00 you might have 400 loans
and indeed on our peer-to-peer portfolio
I've got like a hundred loans out there
at the moment and so at borrower one now
becomes bankrupt he goes charging off
and lives in his mother's basement and
decides not to give us any more money
what happens is I've only lost one of my
400 loans and so it's okay that you can
actually sting that sort of loss and if
course as time goes on or the other
borrowers come up so like this borrower
to maybe
lender to here doesn't really like the
look of this loan and so lender to
doesn't learn it and of course borrow to
only pays back to interest in principle
to the lender one and lender three so
the system of course is much more
insulated for the the organizer here if
the loans go bad it's only the lenders
that have problems and the central
organizer won't become bankrupt and we
won't have global financial crisis and
so that's the idea behind peer-to-peer
lending and so there's the question is
is this risky and so here's this cheesy
sort of ad they had for the peer-to-peer
lending and we've got nice little smiley
you know in the literature and the
advertisements you've got nice little
smiling investors and a smiling borrower
and everything looks nice and smiley and
happy but of course it's somewhat new
and it might all come down in some
flaming pile of bankruptcy and it might
be really bad and there are definite
risks so I won't talk about you know the
economy changing and all of those things
so much so let's talk about peer-to-peer
lenders in America Lending Club prosper
upstart funding circle on the citizen of
New Zealand actually New Zealand er and
so they've got this in New Zealand
harmony that's unsecured in other words
the people borrowing money don't need to
put up their car or house
it's fractionalized Squirrel money is
somewhat similar but it's it's secured
and it's good it's a little bit
different and so there's these various
variations and I'm gonna talk about
harmony okay so let's take a look at
some example peer-to-peer loans here I
don't know if people can actually sort
of read this I'll read it out here's
here's one of the loans that you can
actually see that comes up in harmony
here its III loan so it's a bad grade
but to pay twenty five point six percent
Interest it's over five years it has an
expected default rate of four point
three eight percent so that's that's the
that's the percentage that they might
just run off and it's he's this person
is asking for eight thousand seven
hundred dollars he's for household items
and he's giving his reason here I am
moving into a flat that's for the
Americans that's an apartment I'm moving
into an apartment this money will help
me furnish my room also helping me
repair my car and I also intend on
taking a holiday to Fiji thanks sorry we
might take a look at this thing I don't
know so this guy's
and come here 1700 he's borrowing more
than 10% of his wage here he's living in
a place called Huntley he's still with
his parents of course that's why he
wants to move into an apartment yeah
maybe I'll fund him maybe I won't and so
you see this various loans like this
here's another one
it's a b3 it's got fourteen point four
nine percent interest it's only got a
default rate of 0.21% so the interest
rates gone down but the default rate has
really gone down as well strangely of
course he's listed his reason as a
computer and he's got he wants to borrow
thirty-two thousand dollars and he's 59
years old maybe he's buying a rack
server I don't know you take a look at
various details and so on and so you can
see these various different loans d5
paying twenty two point nine percent two
point six percent default rate and a c5
c1 here paying sixteen point four nine
percent and at default rate so now you
being the math mathematical type people
that you are you wonder well these
people are possibly defaulting at
various times but they pay a higher
percentage what's the optimal way that I
should structure my portfolio so that I
I make money so to simulate this what
we're going to do is there's three
things that can happen for any investor
one the investor in any one month can
make a payment to they could actually
pay everything off or three they could
go bankrupt and pay us nothing and so
then this is just basically a simulation
of collecting up all the interest
payments reinvesting them over time
taking the fraction of money that
harmony scrapes from us paying some
taxes and doing some other bits and so
we need to simulate this all over time
and so here's the simulations here's
just the code I'm not going to talk
about it too much I'm just sort of
saying this parallel table here and what
we're doing is we're basically getting
three data sets just grade b2 by itself
grade b5 by itself and grade b2 and b5
and so each one of those that's that to
run that on my laptop takes about ten
minutes to actually generate those and
we can get some really nice
visualizations sorry really nice
visualizations here and see what's
what's going on so here we see our B to
grade it's quite secure there's a very
low default rate so quite a lot of the
time you'll actually hit the perfect
thing where nobody defaults at all so we
get a nice big spike right there at 11%
paying 11%
but then every so often some people are
when we simulated our gonna default b5
we'll also get a reasonable spike some
of the time you'll actually get it
through and b5 that no one will default
but it's less likely and so that that
level there is lower than there and then
you get this sort of distribution curve
and here excuse me is the combination of
the b2 and b5 and you know you just
can't sort of add those things so we've
we've somehow I've got to put we've
somehow got to put this all together and
simulate this in a nice way and I have
just lost the Clippy bit right I'll just
hold it there
so and with somehow got to put this all
together in a way on the iPad that we
can actually have some interactivity and
and simulate this so what we're gonna do
here is put this together and take a
look and I'm gonna turn it like so and
we are in fact just to show you I've got
nothing in my sleeve
I'll quit the kernel here and show you
that this loads like so and we can see
the loading loading loading and it's
already loaded here and here we've got a
selection of various grades that we're
going to we're going to simulate and we
can just set this running here and now
we can actually see this over time
sorry we can actually see what's
happening and we see we're getting right
here sort of return of about fifteen
point five plus or minus maybe 0.5% with
this selection of grades and so of
course we might be a bit more of a
bottom feeder we might just go down and
really get some really nasty grades here
that he grades as well and so you notice
as I change this
we're regenerating this week we're going
to have new results and we see our
return or average returns gone up but of
course it's we're getting a bit more of
a spread and over time this will
actually build up we do have in here of
the application we have this charged-off
multiplier and so that's that's
basically to model if economic
conditions get a bit worse so in other
words let's say the default rate goes up
to maybe twice so there's twice as many
people the economy's tough twice as many
people are defaulting on their loans as
before and now we can see we've
decreased our rate of return and so
we're giving some instant feedback and
so this is sort of put the whole thing
together and I want to just sort of say
with
I'm gonna quit this here again and we
note here in the player right the player
here it's remembered our selection so
here we're using local storage from
before the same technique that we built
up to actually remember what were the
selected grades that we're actually
running and it uses the same technique
to get this loaded to actually load the
package and so these are the basic steps
that we need to build start building the
application I could have made it more
complicated but then my notebook would
have been a little bit harder to follow
so I've sort of left it here but of
course we might have some input fields
store some stuff in the cloud take an
order and we say to some clients that
yes would you like to invest in this
right now or or so on and so we can
build up more complicated applications
on the iPad okay
well that brings me to the end of my
talk
you
[Applause]